charges have now been filed against a
white man who allegedly shot an unarmed
black teenager who was at his front door
84 year old Andrew luster is his name he
is charged with two felonies assault in
the first degree in armed criminal
action sixteen-year-old Ralph yarrow was
shot twice and is now we're happy to say
recovering at home y'all's family says
he was just trying to pick up his
younger twin brothers when he mistakenly
went to the wrong house Lester told
police he thought someone was breaking
in and that no words were exchanged
before the shooting the prosecutor says
there is a racial component to this case